well so today we are talking about
pac-man uh which is a game from the
early 80s and obviously uh one of the
definitive arcade games
and something that probably a lot of
people don't know because most people
don't spend their time compulsively
playing video games is that pac-man
comes to a dead halt at level 255. we're
going to be talking today about the
number 255
have you ever got to level 255 uh no
pac-man's not my game so i've made it to
level 20 or 30 and then normally i need
a wii or something and so
i guess what this relates to is the way
computers and microchips were built back
in the early 80s they were all just
eight bit processors and what that meant
was that they had eight lines inside the
processor for carrying the numbers on
which limited what the computers could
do today i'm going to show you how and
why that limits what computers can do
well i'm going to start by showing you
how computers count
computers count in i think called binary
which basically means they have on and
off
so let's start
with off and we're going to pretend that
this is a computer with four bits and
for the number zero each one of those
lines
is set to zero
so all i'm going to do is start adding
numbers to the rightmost column i'm
going to add a 1 to the zero
and then the rest of the numbers stay
the same and that is the number one so
now we're going to aim to add another
one to go to the number two
so when i add a one to this column in
binary there's no more space in this
column okay so what we're going to have
to do now is carry one into the next
column exactly the same as adding 1 to 9
would be in decimal so i add 1
that becomes a 0 and we carry 1 into the
next column and the rest of the columns
stay the same and that is the number two
so for number three
what we're going to do is add one to the
two so naught plus one
is one
this column remains unchanged
and these columns remain unchanged okay
now then the number four
well that's three plus one so i add one
to this column and it has to carry so we
get a zero
which means i add one to this column and
again it has to carry so i get another
zero and i carry into this column
and that is unchanged again that is the
number four okay let's rattle through a
few more i'm gonna write down the number
six which is not one one
zero the number seven
naught one one one the number fifteen
one one one one and then we get to the
number 16
and we have a problem
okay because i'm going to add one to
this column
which means it's got to carry
which means i have one to this column it
has to carry i have one to this column
it carries
i have one to this column and so it
carries we run out of space i don't have
another line
to add a number to because what i want
to do is put one
here
but that as far as the computer is
concerned this simply doesn't exist
so what's happened we've wrapped back to
where we started from
so we've we've hit a dead end um and we
can only count to 15 using a four bit
number and what i want to do is take
this back to the pac-man problem okay so
pac-man had a microprocessor which was
an 8-bit microprocessor not a 4-bit
microprocessor and what that means is
that if we want to represent the number
zero we need eight zeros
one two three four
one two three four okay let's do it
again the number one
what about the number two
i'm going to be drawing a lot here but
okay i'm gonna do the number eight
now let's skip up just a few more to
what would be the number 250
okay so we're getting close to the end
here one zero one okay the number 254
the number 200
and we've come back to a point
where we reach a familiar problem if i
want to count to 256
here we go i'm going to add 1
to 255 so it carries here
it carries here it carries here and here
and again it carries here here here and
here
and i want to put one here
but the computer pac-man simply doesn't
have a number big enough to store that
value and we're scuppered
okay so that's it that is why 8-bit
computers can only count to the number
and as a child i was fascinated by this
absolutely fascinated but it's taken me
15 years to get to the point where i can
explain it to you